[Music]
he guat thank you for joining me startup
Nation United we're in November 3rd so
28 days into into the war after the
terrible October 7 occurrences you've
been one of the most I think active
players
contributors H Spirits during this time
I think that things you've experienced
from
from from springing into action the
social impact the the act the tangible
impact on the situation right when this
war unfolded all the way to actually
serving in reserves and being and being
you know within the within the efforts
on the ground and then uh operationally
continuing to be a leading Force within
the ecosystem I think that's a it just
speaks a testament to to who you are as
part of and what your You Know Your Role
with within the the amazing startup
Nation ecosystem so thank first of all I
want to share a a quick def you know
inspiration from my end but I thank you
for sharing this time with me I know how
busy you are tell me a little bit about
you know who you are outside the context
of this war and the context of this
conflict oh thank you thank you Michael
for the
opportunity uh I'm guy katovich as you
mentioned I'm a founding partner at
Fusion for the sake of this interview
from uh from an itch an Israeli IC
perspective Fusion is a is a pred
platform for Israeli startups think of
us as the equivalent for what y
combinator as an accelerator and a pred
platform is doing in Silicon Valley and
throughout the world this is what we aim
to do and actually doing for the last
almost seven years in Israel we invested
in more than 100 companies usually
almost uh uh uh every time as the first
check in and besides giving them money
we're also giving them our let's say
immersive platform of
content workshops and introductions to
clients and and fall on investors with
the purpose of helping Israeli Israel
Founders get going wherever they are
whenever they are so that's what we did
over the last seven years 100 companies
and accumulated valuation of more than a
billion dollar we have already a bunch
of successful exits behind us and every
other month we do we do a bunch of
Investments uh locally here in Israel so
that's idea so besides besides
Investments you're also very active
energy within the ecosystem whether it's
you know the engagement with early stage
Founders you're you're effectively get
being the first check you really are
sort of a foundational layer into this
ecosystem so share with me just a little
bit about what you're how you're
experiencing you know the ecosystem in
Israel the startup Nation you know that
from from a from a preed perspective you
really working with them with us you
know I have the pleasure of also being a
part of fusion myself you're working
with us from the literally Day Zero um
and and building us up so I'd love to
hear a little bit about your experience
of this preedee early stage experience
within Israel yes so so you mentioned
our other activities within the local
ecosystem so yes part of our strategy is
to give content and workshop and tools
and teach methodologies of how to build
startups for every Israeli entrepreneur
not necessarily those that are part of
our portfolio so we have a very active
entrepreneurial Community thousands of
people are members of our community
they're not necessarily portfolio
Founders and we're doing a lot of events
over the last last six seven years we
did more than 400 events that are open
to Israeli uh audience whether they are
fers or people that want to get going
with their startups and I'm also like
you a content creator and I have uh at
least two podcasts that I'm running here
locally in Israel one of them is focused
on on Tech Investments and how to build
a startup and another one is more on the
growth mindset and self growth and as
you mentioned we are very much involved
in the ecosystem at a broader scale
because this is what you know part of
how we see our role within the ecosystem
regarding this let's call it the state
of the pred funding I would be honest I
think uh I think considering everything
that's going on it's pretty early to
determine what would be the effect of
this of this war on the ecosystem uh I
think that at the immediate level of
course and naturally we saw a decrease
in attention of investors whether they
are VCS or Angels or other you know
early stage vills because everybody was
dealing with the war whether they were
on reserve duty doing social you know
civil volunteering or just trying to get
their uh mental and emotional
together uh but I think that now looking
at it from a broader perspective talking
with dozens of Co colleagues I think we
can we can definitely say that three
weeks after one of uh the most you know
uh horrible attacks in in in the the
last decades um Israel is really getting
stronger and people are getting back to
business so this is
encouraging wonderful you know going
back to October 7 we hit all of us in in
different capacities 6:30 a.m. October
7th H how did this whole thing unfold
for you
personally so for me as a citizen first
of all I I was asleep when the first uh
Rockets were shot at Tel Aviv I woke up
uh at my bed with my significant other
and we immediately went to take
shelter uh in our building and after a
few hours the events unfolded for us as
well as for everyone else we realized
that there was you know a big attack
with a lot of atrocities that happened
there in the South and we realized that
we have to do something so no more than
24 hours uh after the first events we
called to a bunch of people and I
specifically gave gave a call to a guy
named nrod Arin who is the main producer
of the Nova Festival the the nature
party that happened back in the South
and told them n he was luckily alive he
was one of the main producers his sister
by the way got murdered in the same
party that he organized and I called him
and I told him Nimrod his nickname is
nimi I I called and told him nimi uh
let's build a a civil war room together
uh meet me at so and so and let's start
working so Nimrod and a bunch of his
produc friends for the production of the
Nova festival and US gathered in an
office of a tech company in Tel Aviv and
started to work in work on building what
would be called later on uh the itch
Civil War Room which is a civil
grassroot initiative of a lot of people
from the Israeli tech industry in order
to help you know um both Army units to
get supplies and stuff that are needed
but also in order to to uh to help I
would say with the discovery of people
that their tracks were lost in the south
after after those events uh so we did
both of uh those activities in parallel
raising donations in order to buy
equipment and deliver those to the Army
uh definitely on the first two weeks of
of the war and then also in parallel
working with a lot of technological and
data related Tools in order to help the
production company of the Nova Festival
find out the geolocation the locations
of people that were missing after the
festival and we were happily and luckily
if I can use those words in that context
uh we're successful in fighting almost
40 people uh D with this during the
activity of this war room so that's what
we did uh that was the first thing that
we did actually that's uh unbelievable
talk to me about this springing into
action so 24 hours there's multiple
aspects here you know there's there's
the immediate you know spring into
action calling and and making and
organizing everything and actually
operationalizing it in matter of in
matter of hours but then there's also
the involvement of people who were were
highly affected I think that these two
concepts really speak volumes to the
nature of of how we live and and and our
way of life both entrepreneurially but
also as Citizens how how you know why
spring into action so quickly what was
going through your mind what does this
reflect for you on on our ecosystem at
large yeah if if I if I understand you
correctly then then I'll be honest and I
think that this is my way of coping with
the situation uh at first when the event
just happened on October 7s like
everyone else I was shocked I was
surprised I was sad I was panicking uh I
was shaking sitting in my sofa just
scrolling through telegram getting the
news seeing the videos of the atrocities
that happen in the South like everyone
else and after a few hours I found
myself you know I looked at myself from
above and said wow guy you've been been
sitting here uh with your partner for
the last few hours just scrolling to the
news Let's uh try and do something uh
something useful so that's where I
called nin and luckily picked up he was
alive and we started
working unbelievable okay so place the
situation for a second if I were to walk
into this into the Civil the Hightech
civil war room if I go in there on the
Tuesday three days later what am I
experiencing what what am I seeing what
what am I experiencing what is the
energy who is
there so you're getting into an office
of a grow stage tech company in Israel
called Walnut by the way I don't know if
you had the pleasure of interviewing
your vilner who hosted us for no cost
there of course nobody was in the office
from Walnut because all the people were
going to reserve duty to miluim or just
were dealing you know volunteering in
other places and uh what you would seen
there is a a fancy office of uh Israeli
startup with all the perks and then the
first thing that you would see when you
open the the the doors you would see
dozens of boxes with a lot a lot of
equipment that will soon be sent uh to
Army units whether they're in the South
or in the north and some also to other
civil families of civilians that were
evacuated of the South and the north so
both and then if you would go deeper
into the offices you would see that the
rooms fills with volunteers that are
either working on the computers making
calls to Army units to make sure what do
they need or to people of uh uh you know
to families of people that were involved
with the Nova Festival to make sure that
we can help them and give them uh
assistance as they needed and and yeah
and and and other rooms full of people
that were calling donors in order to
raise money so we actually built this
operation in in less than 24 hours and
it was pretty amazing to see how many
people that didn't know each other
gathered in the same space in order to
create an impact uh for the benefit of
the of Israel and the Israeli
Society how did this continue to unfold
for you personally over the next couple
of weeks you were called into reserve
duty ER how how did you continue being a
part how did this conflict continue on a
personal level for you yes so so for me
after an parallel of of building the
civil war room I was in touch with my
people in the Army asked them to go on
reserve duty I did that and still I'm
doing that in some capacity as as we
speak right now even though I'm not
wearing uniform uh I've been serving in
the Army uh for six years and since then
I've been doing a reserve duty like
every other Israeli every once and then
and then after ref felt that the Civil
War Room has been stabilized uh we
nominated a leadership to take uh to
take a lead of this initiative and I
started to also get uh uh to put more
focus on on Fusion portfolio company
because if uh you remember and you were
with us at the beginning of the
interview I'm also running an investment
platform with more than 100 uh 100
active portfolio companies so we need to
be there for our funders as well so we
immediately started to do what we know
how to do best which is to create a
platform for them whether we are talking
about workshops and content or
connection or just a safe space for them
to share in relation to the situation so
we already gathered them more than a
couple of times uh with uh you know uh
psych psychologist and therapist and and
organizational coach that can help our
Founders you know deal with this complex
insane situation and learn and discuss
how to run the company properly when
you're in word time actual word time
CEO um and in parallel we try to reach
out to almost everyone and make sure
that they haven't been affected so much
of the situation whether they're going
to reserve duty or not do they need are
help in backup can we help with
connections or supplies or stuff like
that and make sure that everyone are
okay so yeah uh we did and we are still
doing that so having an
observation to more than 100 early stage
startups in the Israeli ecosystem
Israeli Founders you know this is a very
these are very delicate stages right
these these companies that were running
they're not yet you know they're they're
not yet at a point where it's a
necessarily a well oiled machine
there's a lot of moving pieces and we're
adding the complexity of wartime
emergency and now as entrepreneurs we
have to even be be even more
entrepreneurial and and have more
resilience what what has been your
observation over these NE over these
three weeks as you know to the 100 plus
um community members under Fusion that
you see are dealing with this either
from how the founders have been dealing
this how the companies have been dealing
with this what has been your experience
of the of the early stage ecosystem in
response so all in all I don't want to
sound too cliche but you know when
you're are facing very big unusual
challenges then you can see some people
their entrepreneurial Spirits actually
Thrive so it's really interesting to see
and maybe it sounds like a cliche about
the Israeli founder you know Israel
typical entrepreneur that can break
through walls quot quote unquote but you
really see that despite
all the hardship some of the team
members are getting called to reserve
duty some people that they know maybe
they lost their life and and got
murdered on the day of October 7 uh
they're still being very resilient on an
average level and then keep doing the
work in order to get their company going
of course there are let's call that
objective variables that affect the
ability of a company to operate if you
run an a round or a B round
uh let's say startup and half of your
team is being now called to reserve duty
and the others have to stay home and
work from home uh because uh the
educational system is halfly you know
half partially working so you need to
stay with your with your kids at home
then of course it will have an effect uh
on the operation on the on your startup
on the operational level but I think on
alone when you talk with the people hear
from the spirit and look at it from the
bird ey point of view I think that
people are getting the most out of the
situation um uh and and you know there
are startups that have been objectively
affected by it because the team was
called to reserve duty and have to stay
at home but there also a lot of
companies that are keep doing business
as usual and just keep bringing on
clients and raising on money uh such as
yourself by the way Michael which is
amazing I think one of the one of the
key elements that I'm I'm constantly
being inspired by and I hope that
investors and and others you know both
from Israel and abroad are you know
observing to is really a testament to
the resilience of of the of
entrepreneurs that are coming out of
Israel and I think that these are times
when you think about due diligence when
you think about you know what types of
Founders people want to back I mean I
can't imagine more strous rigorous
situations than than a wartime to be
able to look at at founding teams and
early employees and see okay is this a
company that we believe can can manage
through hardships and through the
difficulties of running a company and I
think that you know and I'm very you
know happy to to see how so much of the
community is so resilient and and and
part of that is is working together into
this ecosystem and so when I'm thinking
about you know the impact that that
we're going to have on the investment
side on our ecosystem moving forward
also postwar I'm very optimistic that
the world will see what you know the way
that our ecosystem has been handling the
situation how early stage startups have
been handling it and it will just give
more optimism and more enti and more
energy into investments in our ecosystem
is that is that also how you've been
seeing it yes I would also talk about it
from a different prism which is which is
it it i w I don't want to say it doesn't
matter what what the role is thinking
because of course it does but I think
that we as are as Israelis Now
understand the important the importance
of it our ability to thrive in times of
difficulties and also when you look at
it in the grand scheme of things Israel
is really a miracle when you think about
it a company with you know with the
stats and numbers that we have you know
in terms of GDP startups per capita the
amount of money that has been investment
in in the tech ecosystem the amount of
unicorns and startup and companies that
has been ipoed in Wall Street uh that
are coming out of Israel which is just a
10 million people State uh and when you
look at it from a historical point of
view you have a war or a military
operation here every two to three years
it's just crazy and this despite all of
that the economy is
thriving cost of living is getting up
quality of living is getting up and all
the you know civil systems including the
econ the economy and the tech uh
industry itself in it are are growing
consecutively over the last few decades
so it's really really interesting to
see so finally transitioning just to to
Fusion it's you're not only supporting
supporting the ecosystem not only um
serving the ecosystem and with your time
and your energy with the civil war room
and reserves you've also continued being
operational as an early stage fund
you've you mentioned that you've already
you've continued making Investments even
over this last mon which I think is is
unbelievable um how do you maintain you
know what what is Fusion doing today
with in the context of what's Happening
how have you maintained operationalizing
throughout this
war yes so so our claim to fame is to be
the first check into companies and to
invest before VCS and angels and be like
your friends and family let's say so we
take bets in companies where other
people can't and we take vs in times
when other people can't so I think that
if this is our claim to fame this is our
let's call that our calling even uh to
invest and to double down on Israel
during these tough times so over the
last months we invested in 12 new
companies one two uh nine of them were
new Investments three of them were
followup in investments in companies
that we already put the first check in
to our accelerator and we are now
looking at let's say two to three more
concrete deals meaning that we we you
know we started seeing we we backed into
seeing companies and deal flow once
again and to be honest at the first week
or so after October 7th we were we
weren't that active but we were
gradually back into activities and now
we're almost 100%
on incredible and all of this in in 28
days everything we just spoke about
everything in 28 days uh and most of it
happened within the first week of the of
the war so uh I think that's just an
important context for us to keep in mind
the time frame that we're that we're
talking about which I think is
unbelievable guy thank you so much for
everything um thank
you thank you first of all as a as a
Founder that that you're supporting
thank you as an Israeli citizen that
you're supporting with all the amazing
work and thank you for the inspiration
over these over these 20 or so minutes I
really appreciate it thank you thank you
Michael for your time I appreciate as
well and uh stay safe good
[Laughter]
luck